mettez
Et
[musique]
évidemment, nous continuerons d'essayer et nous
nema boarding disparaissent en choisissant ici et
liberté et je suis la première fois qu'un dictateur
programmes
[musique]
tout d'abord, je suis fier de mon président
que j'ai choisi et il est incroyable
Humain
c'est une personne très claire et profonde
moralement et il représente très
digne de l'ukraine
dans les parlements
[musique]
différents pays et dans leurs discours et
discours d'ouverture de Cannes
festival, il a prononcé un discours étonnant
Koltchak derrière un bureau pour un dialogue silencieux avec le VIH
les bouleaux combattent encore la solution isabel
Tous
faire un hôtel de voleur alcha fak
[musique]